Speaker 1: Sanna Marin, the prime minister
of Finland, has been under fire lately for
one of the dumbest political scandals imaginable,
for partying and dancing and having a good
time, the clips of which were made public.
Moran is 36 years old, making her one of the
youngest world leaders.
And good for her.
She likes to have fun every now and then go
to house parties in nightclubs and dance,
presumably have a few drinks and just all
around, have a good time.
And she's actually had to respond to criticism
over this, both from the Finnish people and
from people across the world.
There are some right wing commentators here
in the U.S. who are making a fuss about this,
saying that this is unbecoming of a prime
minister.
What if she was on drugs?
What if there was an emergency that she had
to deal with at that very moment?
What would the world have done?
And it's clear to me that a lot of these attacks
are a just and misogynistic, because you want
to make them about an older man, for example.
But let's first check out the ever so controversial
video of her partying and having a good time.
Speaker 5: Fine.
Hmm.
I think.
So it's so.
Speaker 1: I mean.
All right.
So if you were just listening and you were
in watching along there, she's just dancing
and making some cool poses and having some
fun with her friends.
There's really nothing out of the ordinary
about it.
But despite all this, she had to give a response
to reporters.
Moran has said in response to the videos that
she's agreed to take a drug test, which I
don't think that she should have had to do
or should have been pressured into.
But the results of that drug test are supposedly
coming come out within the week.
And she's also made the statement, I did nothing
illegal, which is very much true.
And even in my teenage years, I have not used
any kind of drug.
And then in response to the idea of like,
oh, well, what if an emergency came up?
She said, I don't remember a single time that
there was a sudden situation in the middle
of the night to go to the State Council palace.
I think my ability to function was really
good.
There were no known meetings on the days I
was partying.
So this readiness to respond if there was
an attack or something seems to be based on
the presumption that she was drinking.
And we don't know, by the way, if she was
drinking or drinking to excess, but even if
she was like, this is not a standard that
we hold to other leaders, other world leaders,
that they can't have a drink every now and
then, that they can't get a little buzz going.
Why is this being unfairly applied to her?
And then after the initial clips came out,
we also got a clip of Moran dancing with someone
who is not her husband.
And some people were upset with that, even
though if you look at the video, the dancing
seems pretty platonic.
And she's actually trying to back away from
the guy who making advances on her.
She at one point puts her arm up.
So that's the situation.
Any way for her to deal with her husband with?
Right.
It's not really a matter of public interest,
in my opinion, but it's another thing that
they can criticize her for.
And the big takeaway really is that people
need to chill out a little bit and let loose
and not take things so seriously all the time.
And if you're one of those people who are
just too uptight and you can't let loose every
now and then, at least let other people let
loose and not take things so seriously all
the time.
And also, let's apply these criticisms equally,
please.
Like when Donald Trump danced to the YMCA,
people were making criticisms about his dancing
abilities.
Right.
Because it looks kind of awkward.
But aside from that, no one was saying, oh,
he needs to take a drug test and this is unbecoming
of a president of the United States.
And what if we were attacked at that given
moment?
Would he have been able to respond?
No one was saying that.
But apparently people are willing to make
these criticisms against Moran because she
actually can dance and she's young and a woman
and all of these different things.
So it's definitely a double standard.
It's pretty transparent.
And the bottom line is people just need to
chill out and apply these
standards equally.